mon entreprise c'est de la plantation du
café à la
récolte jusqu'à la transformation et à
la vente à des patissier à des
restaurants et un peu de café vert en
grain vend du sousv à l'étranger à des
torfacteurs c'està-dire des ma
torfacteur vont recevoir mon produit non
cuit ils vont le torfier à leur façon
alors les cuissons seront différentes ce
sera au goût du pays je travaille seul
ma femme m beaucoup à la récolte prend
des congés mon rôle c'est de c'est de A
jusqu'à Z quoi pour l'instant alors
souvent je suis aidé par des stagiaires
qui viennent du lycée agricole de
Saint-Joseph et je pense qu'il y aura un
développement parce qu'on va s'agrandir
dans des grand dans surface j'aurai
d'autres parcelles plus de production
plus de produits je pense que d'ici 2 à
3 ans j'aurai à peu près de employés le
point fort de ce produit c'est une Drée
rare et surtout ça se vend très cher
dirit pas les prix c'est
descemb Patrice je l'ai rencontré quand
il a fait sa formation chez nous et donc
on est venu voir sa parcelle donc il
faisait déjà de l'agroresterie voir de
l'agroécologie il appliquait les
principes qu'il avait vu dans la nature
mais il arrivait pas à mettre un nom
dessus nous ce qu'on a fait on lui a
appris les processus pour qu'il
comprennent pourquoi ce qu'il faisait
était bien et pourquoi comment on
pouvait encore aller plus loin Patrice
c'est pas non seulement qui mérite de
gagner c'est qu'il va gagner déjà pour
commencer pourquoi parce que il est
inscrit dans une politique durable et
qui devrait être le crédau de l'Europe
entière voire du monde donc je vois pas
pourquoi on pourrait pas donner sa
chance à quelqu'un qui produit quelque
chose de de meilleure façon et qui est
très
bon auparavant j'étais pâtissier glacier
dans la région bordelaise j'ai fait 200
en Suisse àmanique j'étais je travaillis
à l'étranger et puis quand je suis
revenu à la Réunion c'est là que
vraiment je me suis dit tiens je fais le
la culture de café c'est un retour en
arrière je fais ce que faisait mon
grand-père la création d'entreprise si
j'étais tout seul ça aurait été
compliqué je pense alors c'est pas ça je
répète souvent c'est important j'aiété
aidé par la den par r entreprendre et
aussi par la D de pour le projet leader
alors ces gensl vraiment ils sont très
pointus je mot et sans eux je serai pas
là aujourd'hui au niveau de vie privée
l'entreprise prend une bonne place bon
la famille avant tout et en second c'est
l'entreprise voilà et tout va bien alors
moi si je devais définir en deux mots
Patrice je dirais que c'est on va dire
un funambule alchimiste alors funambule
pourquoi parce que c'est un métier qui
est pas évident ça dépend des de
climatique c'est aussi un bon équilibre
avec la terre la nature c'est de
comprendre un petit peu son espace son
environnement mais en même temps c'est
un alchimie parce que il faut des doses
de patience il faut du courage il faut
de la connaissance de la passion c'est
ça en fait
Pat alors patri mérite de gagner le
champ de créateur parce que c'est une
personne authentique comme son café
c'est une personne en fait aujourd'hui
qui a
su transmettre l'identité créole à
travers son savoir-faire et je trouve
que à travers le café il a trouvé
vraiment sa
passion le challenge des créateurs
pourrait m'apporter la notoriété vous
êtes là aujourd'hui c'est un tremplein
pour moi me faire connaître faire
connaître mes produits et peut-être
réinvestir si j'ai le prix participez au
prix du public votez pour votre candidat
favori jusau 27 novembre sur
ww.cg974.fr et la page facebook
challenge des
créateurs